our first filipina guest account this is
excited I am very excited we Amanda
Lopinot guess I have plenty of relatives
who are filipino and I grew up in
Glendale but yeah now it's really cool
to have you on the show because um I've
been wanting an asian chick to come on
the show for a long time and I have one
no guys have like a check off list oh my
god is that is my check off list to get
girls to come on the show and that's it
even if the girl came on to me I'd be
like whoa lady I just want you for a
review hi I'm right right and i'm
jeannie and i'm leilani torres welcome
two reasons to see we are going to give
you some reasons to see and not to see
vampire academy' let's fang whatever
that means I like I will give you
reasons the theme have come this is a
white list of reason I've come from the
north bearing reasons i bestow them upon
their reason to see number one it's fun
bad so yeah we saw vampire academy and
vampire academy has like one of the
worst ratings right now iran and
tomatoes and i walked in expecting this
horrible film and you know what it was a
pretty bad film but I quite enjoyed the
hell I really liked this film for some
reason it's everything that people say
about it that look as bad totally agree
it's all there but doesn't really bother
me I really like this film yeah that to
me this movie is kind of like your
plucky little brother who just keeps
[ __ ] up but you want to throw your
arm around him and be like come here you
cuz you're just so [ __ ] goofy I never
did that to any kids the boobs really
helps and the cute little schoolgirl
outfits that were short I think that
helped a lot yeah I especially made my
viewing experience better too it does
help but on the other hand it also kind
of read to me as vaguely creepy because
sometimes are these girls are 18 so it's
one of them is one of them but like all
the rest is never like what's up
cleavage tiny dress we're all 15 to 17
1 18 year old in a drain yeah but come
on man it's a [ __ ] movie we all know
that high school girls are really 18 I
thought about being creepy tonight all
right good stuff waste which see live on
camera ouch we could possibly be related
and you asked that question because
we're both filipina yeah you don't know
there might be some like crazy family
tree I mean I guess we're all made of
matters yeah we are all need a matter
cuz we all matter oh god these jokes get
me a Rita I bet she doesn't want to
switch seats now because that you've
just real perfect you see that people
right on the heels of you making a joke
about how you're probably related really
good creepy wizardess you number two
rose hall forum yeah love rose huff I
love rose Hawthorne I thought she was
great she reminded me of ellen page oh
no no hello Ellen page's is
significantly better and it is
significantly different no they they
have some similarities and they're like
is that Juno yes okay yeah I mean she
has that little like way that she talks
and she's like cute and stuff like that
she's so hot that's the main thing about
her is she's really hot she just won my
heart over I thought she had a great
personality I was falling in love with
this girl even though at times I could
tell she was really acting it was like
let's go down the checklist of acting
choices you can make oh here's one
here's one here's their shitty dialogue
and you are not helping make it any
better I mean like fifty percent of her
performance to me was like it's alright
it's fine like she's either fine or like
you're kind of getting on my nerves now
yeah I'd have to agree but she kept me
along the journey I think you were just
looking at her boobs no it went beyond
the boobs the face was great too and the
personality if you're watching Rose
Hawthorne i would love to date you and i
want to call you Rosa thorn while we're
on a date okay good that's not creepy
either watch a number four
I thought Dmitri like there are times
when his acting is stiff but he did have
sort of a natural he was like harm and
humor about him he's like me buff
Russian Bill Compton and he had like a
heart which was nice no sure sometimes
it's just bad felt like a bad 90s movie
to me like a bad 80s 90s film and I
quite enjoyed watching that for
nostalgic reasons see you all do you
yeah there's an element to any of these
kinds of movies where my inner 14 year
old romance novel reading you know
teenage girl like we'll get into like
there's something where I'm a kind of a
sucker for these kinds of movies or a 14
year old teenager oh yeah it's like your
inner child with my inner yeah it's like
my inner romance novel reading
fourteen-year-old Twihard yeah no I saw
it with all my girlfriends one of my
girlfriends is like purely obsessed with
all the characters and think she loves
rose Hawthorne just as much as you do we
should date oh you guys can we can tell
if you know to this sweet related to oh
we're gonna take the chance and we're
gonna go to quest diagnostics and get a
blood test she loves all the characters
and like the whole Mean Girls aspect of
it there's like all these social
outcasts and like mean things that like
oh the main vampire is becoming you know
clean be did she read the book there's
above no I don't think sober yeah this
is that they're trying to fill the hole
that Twilight has left behind so it's
another book that they yeah it's a
really big book it like really yeah it
goes like ties with me a Bible Lord of
the Rings right Jenna but that's the
thing about it is like the writer of
heathers and the director of Mean Girls
yeah and I like the concept of doing
like vampire love story but also high
school movie but watching this I was
like these are the same guys like this
feels like two dudes who only watch mean
girls and heathers and then tried to
make a very pale imitation of them like
think fab life where did all that talent
go it felt like a fun like young teenage
girl movie
I thought it is but it's a lot of fun it
was so stupid but the thing is like I
can't believe these the same dudes who
made those two movies because it's not
anywhere near as sharp or as paste or as
clever as those ones are always weird or
as interesting it's like they were like
ok these were good and they may just
kind of like half-assed it with this one
I felt that way you know the lines have
been like a little bit like spunkier and
like funnier even though they were ok
really there are you gonna serve one
hundred percent right I enjoyed all that
[ __ ] even the editing and the audio like
30 times I'm like her mouth literally
not moving this what you can hear her
talk there is so much horrible ADR in
this movie and the flight scenes were
headed it really weird to like they was
like whoa didn't she just do that move
but also I feel like the fight scenes
were all shot and edited to mask the
fact that none of these actors know how
to fight yeah that's true but Rose
Hawthorne was pretty sexy when she was
like fighting kind of finds I thought it
was really cute fighting she I was just
cute fighter I get well my only problem
with her fighting specifically is all
those shots looked like they were doing
it very slowly remember she's training
with her when she trained with Dmitri
she's obviously swinging weight above
him yeah I mean stuff I feel like it's a
good like movie to have like on DVD and
you know you could buy it like in the
bin for like five dollars ya could enjoy
it put some popcorn when you don't have
a flake you just have like your
girlfriends yeah all my girlfriends it's
a little vampire high school reman
you're gonna leave angry by any stretch
of the imagination I mean I feel like
she would the amount of like guys that
they put in there they could have put in
like sexier guy just I just would have
preferred to look at someone that was
like pretty like really pretty so what's
your time um I don't really have a type
don't you dimitra was hot and sexy not
my type but I like someone like tall and
kind of dark like a little bit of flavor
chocolate flavors every time i guess i'm
not i don't really have a specific
flavor i just kind of like a little
been in there ah that that makes so much
sense well yeah I wish this didn't feel
like an ABC family movie that's what I
liked about it it was like an ABC family
movie that's the gift and the curse with
it awkward clear words you're like I
should be watching this with commercials
like intermittently paying attention but
instead it's in the theater like
everything is on an ABC family level but
except for know there they could not put
like that kind of violence and an ABC
family sure you don't know that we
described it me and my girlfriend's we
described it as a cross between mean
girls and blade but just not as good as
those two what is a neat idea it's more
like yeah girls and Buffy um no Buffy
the Vampire Slayer take that back well
Buffy only in the sense that it's
supernatural high school but yes I'm of
the sea I didn't think about that yeah
runs right I think we said everything we
have to say about this movie yeah it's
time to wrap this review up what do you
say people let's do it let's do it party
people let's do it should we do it
should we do a huddle about like a hands
in hands ain't happening okay one two
three reasons to see one two three
reasons to see I have to do the down
just down up thing it's like they're
pushing a button yeah it's like whoa
yeah all right okay Ryan's consensus a
shitty movie that is one hell of a good
time is the reason to see vampire
academy' a shitty movie that is one hell
of a good time is the reason to see
vampire academy' yep believe everything
that people say it's bad about it but
enjoy the red cherries consensus an
enjoyably goofy mess is the reason to
see vampire academy' and enjoyably goofy
mess is the reason to see vampire
academy' i mean it's sort of inept on
every level but there's something that's
fun about the whole thing it's one of
those sort of so bad it's fun scenarios
for me Leilani's consensus yeah a sexy
funny girly vampire movie is the reason
to see vampire academy' I approve I
approve a sexy girly funny vampire
movie is the reason to see vampire
academy' good Jesus Christ saved her
life just now that's what happened trust
in our Lord and Savior people oh man all
right guys she's crying she was laughing
a lot that's what just happened it was
awesome it was awesome why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box below and
you tell us what vampire is your
favorite vampire here we go good
question did you reassured yourself yeah
I have to make sure we're asking them
good questions all right and then once
there once you're done with that I come
over here click this button so you can
see more episodes of reasons to see and
last but not least if you want to get
updated every time one of our awesome
videos is out Oh skrag yes subscribe
click only Lonnie she she has us along
store things your fault um the salons
called Wonderland Wonderland oh I just
imagine the w ok you can go to
wonderland by com yeah she's really good
she was telling me how I need to get my
eyebrows done yeah it really hurt my
feelings no no I wasn't saying that you
had to I was just saying that it might
be good for you um do you think like my
eyebrows are bad or yeah I could just
use like a little bit of a haircut um
like maybe a little trim is all just a
little trim like where exactly are we
talking here uh way you should come in
and I can do oh we're gonna do it like
that up well if you pay me I'll give you
my opinion first I wish I went to a
Jewish school I wish I went to a Jewish
school for my first four years of school
and then a Catholic school for my last
14 verse 8 8th grade confusing up
breathe I know that a lot of fun I am
sorry Sookie I am vampire man you must
invite me in yeah meal I don't wanna buy
your assets ok I do declare eric is
coming so yes
you